okay i'm
tired i'm wrapping things up
thanks everyone for watching that's a
fun stream
[Music]
okay final game i'm not ending i'm gonna
make it to the three hour mark
bonus game
i wonder how many people just like
closed the stream once i said
i was going to end things
but it's not over
jimbo would playing at lightning speed
but this is still opening prep
so f3 is an interesting move
wow
okay i have a story about this position
i first
became aware of the existence of this
position
back in 2014
maybe 2013
2013 i think it was 2014.
i was coaching a student at the time
who got this position as black
in like a national
tournament as national scholastic
tournament
and their opponent played exactly this i
think their opponent played d3 and then
f3 but they got to this position
and i remember like looking at the game
afterwards i think my student like took
one of the pawns and ended up losing
and
i was trying to figure out like what the
best move here is for black
and i hope i'm remembering this
correctly because the best move is kind
of surprising
is knight d5
now i'm relying on memory from eight
years ago
but it's a cool move to just target the
the now undefended e3 pawn
and
this is all i remember is that after it
takes we take and somehow the knight is
not trapped and
the engine likes black
so
we'll see what jimberwood does here
yeah we're also sacking g7 although
bishop g7 then there's
counter play along the g file
ooh
jimberwood has no fear now the question
is do i want to sack a rook like this
this this
and this these are my candidate moves
i mean takes e3 queen e2 and then my
knight and my rook are hanging
i think this is the simplest way to go
i'm having a feeling this game might be
over
how how optimistic am i
i want to predict that the game's gonna
be over in the next like five moves
it could get really bad for white really
quickly
oh white did defend the pawn but i i do
win the
the g-pawn
so jim burwood
has to do some damage control this pawn
is still attacked twice
but this pawn is forking two other pawns
king f1 good move
yeah not quite winning
i was running mating two there but uh
i have to work for my win
taking on f3 is no good
yeah i'm thinking queen
queen g5
queen g5 does look nice
i'm looking for ways where i sock the
rook but
i think it's a little bit too bold
queen g5
there's some issue with queen g5
and white takes the pawn
so how to do this actually
i'm realizing i might not even be so
much better here
although it feels like i should be
somehow
[Music]
uh let's play queen g5
it's a move i could have just blissed
out like intuitively
defend the rook apply pressure
so the pawn is attacked twice but my
queen is tied down to defending the rook
i might be threatening to take on h2
because rook h2 i win the night
otherwise i attack the knight three
times
oh there's a really funny line
okay funny line time
takes takes knight f3 bishop h3 oh no my
queen
rook c2
[Music]
king e1 and then bishop g3 mate the
problem in that line is knight takes h3
would be legal
and maybe i can get it a bit differently
could take on g1
i really want to play queen
wait
the bishop defends the pawn backwards
what am i doing
oh no my queen
oh i didn't take it no i wanted to have
fun
[Music]
oh
fun was almost had
but now i'm sad
okay
i'll sadly take the bishop
and then deliver the fork
that could have been a really cool
ending i mean it's still going to be
um decently
decently happy
so i could take the queen with double
check
but the
the better move here is knight g for
the
alternative double check and this is
actually made in two
wherever the king moves
actually no it's not me in the two it's
made in three
if he moves here then it's check here
and then
knight moves anywhere with mates
if king here here it's mate
or here
so queen f2 regardless
whoa it's purple
did you guys see that
it was purple for a moment
unless i'm colorblind
i think it was purple
when i pre-move over the king in check
it overlay blue
with
red
which makes purple
i didn't know purple was possible
i think that was the best part of this
game
of the rare purple for the win
[Music]
can you show the queen sack yeah i'll
share the queen sack
maybe also
almost as stunning as the purpleness
so if uh if takes the queen
i have to improve my acting but takes
here and then uh
this is a nice mating idea
you're not colorblind it was purple
love to see your excitement for the
color more than the mate lol
yeah because uh al-nichas
and it's very rare that you make a
pre-move
over your opponent's king
and then only chess when the king is in
check it's like it glues red
and then when you i can't even
demonstrate it here but when you
pre-move it like it overlays with blue
whoa it's purple